okay so we have a major update on ben
affleck's status as the batman the actor
was said to just be coming back for the
flash movie but we now know that he will
be returning in some capacity for
aquaman in the lost kingdom we're going
to be breaking it all down in this video
but whilst i'm talking in the most
monotone british voice possible i'd love
to hear your thoughts on the update so
make sure you drop them in the comments
as we go through it all i also want to
discuss what i've heard is happening
with henry cavill's superman and why
there's so much back and forth over the
status of the character now if you hyped
then please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for comic book
breakdowns every week with that out the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the video now this comes
directly from jason momoa who shared a
post of both him and affleck together on
instagram amowa posted two photos of the
pair together with the caption reunited
bruce and arthur the rest of it went on
to talk about what happened and
apparently they wanted to keep this a
secret but a warner brothers studio tour
stumbled on set and went through the
backlot they found a dressing room with
the initials ba on it and obviously this
secret would have got out don't know why
he couldn't have just andrew garfield
his way through the next six months that
kind of acting exacts a heavy toll
either way affleck is back and though he
might not be donning the cape in cal he
will be there at least as bruce this is
coupled with him showing up in the flash
so he'll be getting at least two
appearances of him you also have michael
keaton playing a version of the dark
knight in that movie as well and we know
that he's returning for batgirl on top
of this we have robert pattinson playing
batman and yeah i don't i don't think dc
know what they're doing but you know
what i'm here for it just bring every
batman back ever baby my bat nipples are
getting hard spoiler alert
now if you follow the channel for a
while then you'll know that we love
batfleck in the role and i'm really
hyped to see him back i know there's a
lot of arguments online every day about
which batman that dc should be going
forward with but if they're going to
have three then
let them have it now i'm a big fan of
keaton aflac and pattinson and if they
can find a way for them all to coexist
together in their own timelines then i
don't see why not and there is also
speculation that batgirl may be pushed
back now affleck will cameo in aquaman
and then be killed off in the flash i've
heard a lot of conflicting things about
how he'll be erased but then other
things that contradict this and yeah
there's plenty of time for dc to put
things in place to go with public
opinion it's super confusing if batgirl
doesn't get delayed and at this point
i'm expecting batman to show up in the
marvel to some
because yeah dc who knows what they're
doing now dc of course had a panel at
hall later over the weekend where they
unveiled the first shazam 2 trailer and
also a new one for black adam i think
marvel came in after them and completely
sucked all the wind out the room and
after their phase 5 and 6 announcement
it was difficult to feel like dc had
done all they could that's why i'm
surprised they didn't announce us there
especially with all the buzz that there
was about henry cavill showing up which
turned out to be untrue now ben was
honeymooning at the time with his new
wife jennifer lopez but they could have
said he was going to be in the movie or
have done something more aquaman 2 has a
lot of people threatening to boycott it
because of the whole amberhead thing and
though her role has been reduced that
petition still stands up 4.6 million
signatures so i think this would have
helped to restore some faith in the
studio especially for people like me who
want to see batfleck back now the
filming of affleck took place during the
reshoots for aquaman too also yeah every
time i say aquaman some
in the comments is like actually
actually it's pronounced aquaman yeah
maybe where you live but words yeah
they're pronounced differently depending
on where you live you're stupid
it's 2022 and you still don't know this
you're a [ __ ] idiot and stop writing
in my car
anyway thanks for clicking this video
and with this being part of the reshoot
i think it shows that affleck has a
minimal role that is likely going to
either be part of the film's beginning
ending or even a post-credits scene most
of the movie has been shot and it would
take so much for them to rework the
entire script to have him as a fully
fleshed out character so expect to see
him probably pop up for a scene or two
at most i think what will likely be
happening with the timeline itself is
that the flash will split things off and
we'll get the schneiderverse class as
the previous universe whereas keaton and
co might go forward to the future this
won't necessarily mean that things are
erased and potentially they can pick up
where they left off in another universe
if needs be this will give them an out
for if their next universe underperforms
and they just decide to go into that now
pattinson will continue with the mat
reeves verse which we know is getting a
sequel and i believe the penguin show is
dropping on hbo max next year probably
should have double checked that but i dc
clearly have different timelines and
universes going on so that they don't
actually need to have a full plan in
place like marvel does we still don't
know which continuity that black anime
is in and in all honesty i don't think
that warner brothers knows either from
what i've been told that's also the case
with henry cavill too for the next part
of the video i want to go over what i've
heard is happening with his version of
superman it's probably something you've
heard touched upon in other things but i
thought i'd go over what i'd heard from
people behind the scenes that have their
own sources and contacts at warner
brothers now they said that henry isn't
out completely but that he in the studio
are having a lot of difficulty nailing
down their terms and conditions me
personally when it comes to that stuff i
just click agree and that's probably why
i'm a youtuber now david zazlov took
over control of warner brothers after
the discovery merger and he was
completely perplexed as to why cavill
has been cut as being the character it's
a bit weird that we keep getting these
headless cameos and apparently he wants
a universe built with him as superman at
the center of it originally there were
plans for supergirl to take over after
the flash and though she'll be a big
part of the dceu cavil is who's wanted
at the center of it however it's
apparently coming down to money projects
and also what's going on in the universe
i think that black adam vs superman
would be great but even the rocks seemed
to not fully know what was going on with
the situation when he said this
you should tell him well look you know
that's a great question luke don't
threaten me with a good time because i'm
gonna answer that question
thank god
well
i i will say as you guys know because
we're all in deep with this mythology
and it's been the age-old question of
who would win in a fight between black
adam and superman uh pound for pound
they're pretty close
um
i i guess it probably all depends on
who's playing superman i will just say
that
[Applause]
i'll be i'll leave it at that leave it
at that and um
we'll just go with that one
i think you've got something extra
special to give people we're jumping you
guys had two great questions that was an
awesome way to end that one
i think you guys brought something
really special though to share with
college is that right i did president
rock thank you very much i got one vote
thank you i appreciate it yes so um we
do we have some very very um
uh exclusive yeah tiffany i know
she's used to me being half drunk where
am i going you didn't make it though
um
we have some uh very exclusive footage
just for you for black adam so
so yeah it doesn't exactly seem like a
done deal and now actors have been known
to play koi with questions on upcoming
projects with caval already being cast
as him i don't see why they do this now
cavill apparently wants more money than
the studio are willing to offer and he
also wants a sequel whereas they seem
doing more cameo type roles they
basically want him as a sort of tony
stark after iron man 3 where he pops up
in the team of movies or as someone who
acts as a mentor to the characters like
supergirl however from what i've been
told by my uncle my uncle kevin spoilers
he wants a solo movie which the company
are unsure about taking a risk on there
are some higher ups at warner brothers
that don't know how to make the
character relevant in these current
times and thus they think that anything
centered around him would underperform
if only there was a superman show on
right now that showed you how to make
him relevant but i digress now affleck
coming back shows that there is hope and
that it's likey car keys
who writes this [ __ ] like your car keys
hope it's like your cockeys but yeah
affleck shows that there is some hope
however he is appearing in a diminished
role at the moment where he's likely
just doing a couple of days shooting
whereas cavall's part would be much more
demanding i think it's still all on the
table though and hopefully we hear
something locked in soon
at this point man of steel released
almost 10 years ago and when they were
this deep marvel were up to their third
thor movie whereas we haven't even had a
standalone sequel for dc's flagship
character kind of sucks seeing them
unveil stuff all the way up to phase six
risers still have no idea what warner
brothers are doing now obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
situation with him whether you're happy
to see him back or if you're not me i
just wish they'd make a decision instead
of these constant teasers and actually
lock something in place but maybe that's
what they're doing and we just don't
know it also huge shout outs to the team
over at project justice league 2 who
just dropped a big trailer for their fan
film that takes the original snyder
storyboards for the sequel and makes
them into an animated movie i'll link
that in the description if you want to
go check it out as it's definitely worth
watching if you want more snide events
now we are also running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august all you
have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the news we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if that's you if you want
some emails to watch that make sure you
check out our breakdown of the trailers
that were shown at the marvel event we
go over everything that happened in them
what easter eggs popped up and
definitely go check it out if you want
to know more by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
paul to see you next time take care
peace